okay let me see that left hand i'm
looking for a tan line
are you engaged i mean i'm engaged to
myself that's what i've been saying for
now
okay i've said the same thing too for 46
years oh
just saying wow too all right so
but are you happy i'm very happy are you
in love i mean
i will say this i fall in love more than
once
[Music]
i never want to stop pursuing love is
there anything that's going to be off
limits
oh nothing's offline about this season
heck no love is love i got to do what i
got to do
okay even mr blow-up doll man
i appreciate a good laugh so if i were
to sit you down and say okay you need to
write down
what type of man you like what would
that be i mean i think the biggest thing
is he has to be passionate about life or
what he's doing in life
definitely a good sense of humor and
then kindness i think that's a really
big thing that people kind of overlook
you know when you talk to a server or
just a stranger kindness i have a deal
breaker and what i look for and that's a
smoker
do you have any deal breakers i mean
i've dated a smoker before i mean to me
like love is love and i mean unless
they're like
i don't know a murderer maybe that's a
deal break up married
also i mean it's a bar to set
maybe the expectations are low i don't
know listen i get it i'm in these single
girls streets too i get it
you know this pandemic was really hard
for me and this just really got me
through
a lot and i was hoping to pass the torch
to you
you were the girl who brought the sex
toy last year and of course you did have
a blow-up doll
you had some you had some interesting
guys that were doing the double
entendres all of that fun
stuff um but i like the fact that a lot
of those guys too said we love her
because she is sex positive we love her
because she is free like that and it
makes us feel comfortable to be who we
are
yeah yeah absolutely i mean that's the
thing like i'm embracing who i am and if
the guy can't accept
you know me being sex positive or
talking about sex it's just not gonna
work out
did you face any backlash like from the
public for being so free and so open and
just kind of being who you are
especially when it comes to sexuality
yeah you know there are some people who
are a little
traditional in old school you know but
people around my age and younger like
we're here for in 2021 embrace your
sexuality and be
empowered woman one of the first things
we heard from you say is where where's
the fantasy suite
so how sexy does it get i mean i've been
saying it i have sex in the fantasy
suite
so you heard it here first okay i like
that you get out in front of it why not
there's no off top we all know it
happens but no one's talking about it
there we go i'm done someone booked my
flight haul
all right so the season promo i was
talking about too it looks really good
we see folks crying
you see um you saying do i continue or
do i get like basically get the heck out
of here
yeah i don't know which one you choose
but um
you know do you have a happy ending do
you think i mean whatever and whatever
makes you happy
of course and that's the thing is
embracing everything happens for a
reason and when you embrace
that and that you let go of control then
you find your happiness and uh i'll just
say you know this this journey is not
easy and
if it wasn't for tasha and caitlyn and
some other people that you guys will
find out about
i don't know that i could have done it i
do have to be honest yes
i have had some issues with the bachelor
bachelorette franchise in the past
so i went into this thinking okay all
right i'm gonna watch this
i like you oh i really do i was like
damn i like her
oh my goodness and i get what people
were saying from the last season like
they kind of fell in love with you
because your no holds bar
filtered you have an easy laugh all of
those things i mean i think that's a
wonderful thing to bring to the
bachelorette were you nervous at all
starting to do this were you like what
am i doing i mean yeah there's
definitely nerves
but after the first night and getting to
meet the guys all of that just kind of
goes away
and it's just it's so much fun going
forward and
and what do you think about like all of
us taking this journey with you because
you are kind of opening yourself
up to all of america in a different way
than you do on the bachelor because
you're the focus now you're the featured
you know person yeah i mean i'm excited
for bachelor nation to get to know who i
am a little bit more
um but more importantly meeting the guys
the guys are so great this season
they're cute oh they're hot
i'm here to take this ride with you
katie i definitely am thank you so much
it's gonna be fun
yes you might just have me because i i
have been hands off
but i was what i like i said i like her
yes i wanna see what happens with you i
like you
it's gonna be good all right cool okay
you